you seem to really be embracing this
Star Wars in the fandom and you're
having so much fun am i honest on the
right page here that you're just having
a lot of fun I would rather not notice
how much fun I'm having I would rather
be oblivious to it if I'm having too
much fun just stop I never want to stop
okay I can't stop but these guys who are
doing these shows are really good at
what they do they really make it fun to
be there it doesn't hurt that I'm there
to sell something that I know there's a
market for I've also hurt you in your
opinions on after you've seen the force
awakens and and how you've talked about
it what is it about this particular
movie and what JJ has done and brought
the movie back
it's the visser allottee of it it's the
emotional investment in in in the
characters that I think will be
generated by the quality of the
storytelling it's the new characters
played by Daisy Ridley and John boyega
and Oscar Isaac and I Adam driver that
that I think are going to really seal a
generation that has perhaps that knows
about Star Wars but has not really yet
invested in it I think in these
characters are going to lead new people
into the tent and that you know it
should be a very satisfying experience I
think for all ages obviously the big
line every was talking about Chewie were
home
the Falcon what he said about the Falcon
that he still wants to keep coming back
to it isn't it like the old car after
well he's just like I that gets 30 years
him it was old back in the original
trilogy that's 30 years later it's I'm
even older so doesn't he want a new ship
I think he wants the ship that served
him well the ship that made the Kessel
run in 12 parsecs I don't think there's
anything out there to beat it yet
console is probably more nostalgic than
I
I you know I'm not that way about
machines but but he is mr. Ford once
again I want to thank you very much for
coming back to the franchise for
everything that you've done for the
franchise and before I go
Fandango has done these special force
awakens gift cards like to give you one
sir
oh thank you and yes get me in turn he
does yeah yeah enjoy thank you got to
guess on the back thank you thank you
very much
[Music]
you